Good morning. So I'll be talking about protobrutinib monotherapy, and then later on
in the session, you'll hear about protobrutinib and combinations in CLL. And these are my disclosures.
So as mentioned earlier, covalent BTK inhibitors require wild-type BTK for activity.
Patients on these covalent BTK inhibitors can develop certain mutations, such as C481,
that confer resistance to covalent BTK inhibitors. So non-covalent BTK inhibitors,
such as protobrutinib and nemtobrutinib, are active against both wild-type and C481-mutated BTK.
They don't require that C481 to bind to the kinase domain.
So protobrutinib was first evaluated in the Phase I-II Bruin study. This is probably one
of the largest clinical trials, early-phase clinical trials I ever participated in. There
was a lot of research on this. And it was a lot of research on this. And it was a lot of
research on this. And it was a lot of research on this. And it was a lot of research on this.
There were over 750 patients. And notably, there were over 280 patients with CLL who had
had a prior covalent BTK inhibitor. And this is their waterfall plot in exposure to protobrutinib.
The light blue lines, which is the majority of patients, had discontinued their prior BTK
inhibitor due to progression. The dark blue lines are patients who had discontinued due to toxicity.
And the asterisks delineate patients who'd also seen a prior BCL-2 inhibitor.
And the overall response rate for this entire cohort,
was nearly 82%. And as one would expect, for a BTK inhibitor, these were primarily
partial responses. On top here, we have our progression-free survival data in this study.
For the patients who were exposed to a prior BCL-2 inhibitor, the median progression-free
survival was 16 months. And for patients who were naive to a BCL-2 inhibitor with protobrutinib,
the progression-free survival was 22 months. In the lower left-hand corner, you can see
that patients had excellent activity regardless of their C481 mutational status. And we are seeing
activity as well in patients who've had prior deletion 17P or TP53 mutation. Now, this study
led to the accelerated approval of protobrutinib. But of course, this approval was contingent on a
phase 3 clinical trial. And this is the study that led to that. Protobrutinib versus adalilis
of rituximab or BR. And patients who had been exposed to a prior covalent BTK inhibitor
in the large phase 3 study, patients were randomized either to a brutinib or the investigator's choice.
Patients had to have seen a prior covalent BTK inhibitor. And their characteristics are here
on the right. So over 200 patients on the study, most patients coming on for progression from the
prior covalent BTK inhibitor. About half the patients had deletion 17P or TP53 mutation.
Most were unmutated for IGHV. So very high-risk population. And
patients had a median of three prior lines of therapy. Half had seen prior BCL2 inhibitor.
So the response rates with PROTO here was 65%. And we see our progression-free survival showing
that PROTO clearly performed much better than the ADELA-BR arm. The median PFS with protobrutinib
was 14 months compared to less than nine months when the comparator arm. And median time to next
treatment, which I think always is very important nowadays in CLL, ranged from 20 to 30 months in the
protobrutinib arm. And that was about the same time as the adela-BR arm. So the response rates with
depending on whether they've been exposed to venetoclax.
Now, how does PRRTO perform in the frontline setting? This is a late-breaking abstract at
ASH this past year of PRRTO-BRUTNA versus bendamustine and rituximab and treatment-naive
CLL. The main exclusion criteria was prior deletion 17P mutation. We have our patient
characteristics on the right. Less than 10% of patients had a TP53 mutation.
In terms of the response rates, 94% with PRRTO, 81% with BR. And here we have our PFS curves on
the right, clearly showing superiority of PRRTO over BR. At two years, PFS rate was 94%.
Patients were progression-free, 93% in PRRTO versus 70% with BR.
Now, how does PRRTO compare to abrutinib, one of our covalent BTK inhibitors? This is also a
abstract that was presented at ASH in 2025. There were two cohorts. There's a treatment-naive
cohort and a relapsed refractory cohort. The main thing was patients had to be naive to BTK inhibitor.
Here are the data in the treatment-naive subgroup. So, response rates, 93% with PRRTO,
86% with abrutinib. We're also seeing a slightly higher CR rate with PRRTO. And here we have the
progression-free survival data on the right. And there is clearly a separation of those curves,
fading during PRRTO-abrutinib, over-abrutinib in the treatment-naive group. Here are the data for
the relapsed refractory subgroup. Response rates, 84% versus 75%. And here are the progression-free
survival data. Not much separation in the curves, but we'll see over time. This is just 18 months
PFS rates of 82% and 79%. And I think we're all interested in is the safety profile, right? And so,
the data with PRRTO and abrutinib, just call your attention mainly to the atrial fibrillation,
A-flutter rates, because this is probably the most notable difference between PRRTO and abrutinib.
All grade A-fib flutter was 2.5% with PRRTO versus 13.5% with abrutinib. And even in that higher
risk population, those older patients, still less than 5% with PRRTO-abrutinib, all grades. So,
very well tolerated. I also listed some of those other problematic AEs we see with BTK inhibitors,
channelthralgia, pretty low. This drug is very well tolerated. Now, how do patients with toxicities
with covalent BTK inhibitors do with PRRTO-abrutinib given this favorable safety profile?
I'll just take you back to the original Bruin study where patients were allowed to receive
PRRTO-abrutinib after intolerance to a covalent BTK inhibitor. And you see there was a number of patients
who were enrolled for this reason. And in general, patients who moved to PRRTO after intolerance on a
covalent BTK inhibitor did quite well. I'll bring your attention mainly to the atrial fibrillation
cohort. There were 30 patients that moved over for A-fib, and more than 90% of them did not
experience a recurrence of A-fib with PRRTO after prior covalent BTK inhibitor. And this study did
include patients who'd received Acala and Xano as well. So, when do I use PRRTO-abrutinib for CLL?
In 2026, and this is still early 2026. Again, in 2023, we have our accelerated approval for
after prior covalent BTK inhibitor and BCL-2 inhibitor. In December 2025, we see the FDA
approval specifically for after covalent BTKI. For me, just given the lack of long-term sequencing
data, as well as the emerging use of BTK and BCL-2 doublets, I'm primarily using PRRTO at a
double-exposed patient population. I think about it, obviously,
in the third line and beyond. For my patients who have decided to move to CAR-T, I do use PRRTO as a
bridge. I think it's very well-tolerated and an excellent option. I will consider it in a select
patient after covalent BTK inhibitor, but prior to a BCL-2 inhibitor. And I think the role for
PRRTO is going to expand, likely. We have more fixed-duration combination studies. We have a
greater understanding of resistance patterns and more sequencing data. And with that, thank you.